Las imágenes son terribles y hablan por sí
solas.
Ante el fracaso en el campo de batalla, una
de las últimas estrategias de Rusia en Ucrania,
ha sido, descaradamente, atacar a la población
civil dejándoles sin luz ni calor a las puertas
del duro invierno ucraniano.
Un invierno en el que las temperaturas oscilan
de media entre los 2 y los -5 grados.
Pues bien, se estima que para mediados de
noviembre de 2022 en torno al 40% de toda
la infraestructura de generación energética
de Ucrania ha sido destruida.
Y según el propio gobierno ucraniano es posible
que la cosa no haga más que empeorar.
(Zelensky: Rusia ha dañado el 40% de la infraestructura
energética de Ucrania- Axios)
(Ucrania avisa de más ataques a la infraestructura,
mientras el alcalde urge a Kyiv a prepararse
para lo peor - Reuters)
Durante el otoño las tropas de Putin han
estado utilizando los pocos misiles y bombas
de precisión que les quedan, junto con drones
suicidas comprados a Irán, para destruir
plantas de agua, centrales eléctricas, térmicas,
termoeléctricas e hidroeléctricas.
Y esto resulta clave en un país en el que
la mayoría de la gente que vive en zonas
urbanas depende para su calefacción del calor
que se genera de forma centralizada en estas
plantas.
Es decir, que no sólo hablamos del suministro
eléctrico.
En Ucrania como ocurre en tantos otros lugares,
la gente no tiene calderas en casa sino que
el calor y el agua caliente se generan en
grandes centrales y luego se distribuye por
tuberías hasta las casas.
Pues bien, el resultado de los ataques rusos
es que tanto Kyiv como muchas otras ciudades
están sufriendo restricciones energéticas
brutales: menos horas de calefacción, el
alumbrado público no se enciende o lo hace
al mínimo, y muchos negocios no pueden funcionar
o lo hacen intermitentemente.
Y es que, por supuesto, a parte del frío
y de las dificultades que la gente está pasando
para algo tan sencillo como cocinar, también
tenemos que tener en cuenta los daños a la
actividad económica.
(Con la llegada del otoño y del invierno
la guerra de Ucrania se ha convertido en toda
una guerra de desgaste contra la población
civil, ahora que el ejército ruso parece
convencido de que en el campo de batalla no
tienen demasiadas opciones de victoria.
Lo que estamos viendo, por tanto, es el uso
del clima como arma de guerra.
Tan sencillo como eso.
Putin quiere utilizar el frío para provocar
olas de descontento y hartazgo entre los ucranianos.
Porque, lo cierto, es que una de las pocas
opciones que le quedan ya al Kremlin para
al menos intentar escapar airosos de este
conflicto, es que los propios ucranianos digan
basta ya y fuercen al gobierno de Zelensky
a negociar.
Esa parece, claramente, la apuesta del dictador
ruso.)
Pero más allá de los planes de Moscú, la
realidad, sin embargo, puede ser muy diferente.
Y es que, por sorprendente que pueda parecernos,
lo cierto es que el invierno ucraniano puede
terminar convirtiéndose en una pesadilla
sobre todo para las tropas rusas.
Por mucho que los ucranianos se vean obligados
a pasar frio y a vivir en semi-oscuridad,
los rusos pueden terminar llevándose la peor
parte.
La cuestión es…
¿Por qué?
¿No se supone que el invierno siempre favorece
a los ruso?
¿Cómo puede influir realmente la llegada
del frío, la nieve y las condiciones extremas
en el campo de batalla?
¿A qué bando puede beneficiar y perjudicar
más?
Pues bien, todo esto y más os lo vamos a
contar en este vídeo.
Pero antes, esta vez, toca ver un poco de
historia.
T1 (EL ‘GENERAL INVIERNO’)
Vale, históricamente, el invierno ha sido
uno de los grandes aliados del oso ruso.
(Por ejemplo en 1812, la Gran Ejército de
Napoleón fue vencida en Rusia por el invierno,
sufriendo unas 380.000 pérdidas tanto en
los propios combates como por culpa del hambre
y la hipotermia.
Algo más de un siglo después, en 1941, durante
la Segunda Guerra Mundial, un dictador por
todos conocido condenó a sus tropas a una
debacle aún peor.
Hitler cometió el mismo error que Napoleón
lanzándose a los brazos del invierno ruso
sin que su ejército estuviese habituado ni
preparado.
Algo que le terminó costando a la Wehrmacht
tener que sufrir durísimas derrotas.
Por el camino se quedaron decenas y decenas
de miles de vidas.)
Claro que esta no es toda la historia.
En su historial, Rusia tiene también malas
experiencias con la gélida temporada invernal.
En 1939 durante la Guerra de Invierno entre
la Unión Soviética y Finlandia, los soviéticos
tuvieron que desistir de invadir toda Finlandia
después de perder entre 130 y 160.000 hombres.
Aunque aquí al menos consiguieron un tratado
que les cedió algunos pedacitos finlandeses,
sobre todo en las regiones de Carelia y Salla
Pues bien, aunque habitualmente el invierno
ha sido un aliado para Moscú, la situación
de Rusia en Ucrania podría terminar siendo
muy parecida a lo ocurrido en Finlandia en
el 39…
O incluso peor.
Peor, porque el colapso del frente ruso en
Kharkiv y Kherson, junto al atasco en el Donbass
no se ha producido en invierno…
Sino durante el verano y el otoño.
En lo que, por supuesto, el clima no fue un
actor relevante.
El desastre ruso ha sido provocado sobre todo
por la superioridad tecnológica y la inteligencia
suministrada a Ucrania por sus aliados occidentales
- además de por su tremenda tenacidad, claro
está.
Una ventaja que ahora el invierno podría
incluso acentuar.
La temporada invernal puede poner las cosas
mucho peor para los rusos…
Aunque, por supuesto, para los ucranianos
tampoco será coser y cantar.
Una guerra en un invierno semejante no es
pan comido para nadie.
Pero, ahora bien, llegados hasta aquí la
pregunta es….
¿Por qué le damos tanto protagonismo al
invierno?
¿Cómo puede afectar esta gélida estación
al transcurrir de la guerra?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (¿UN REGALO ‘ENVENENADO’?)
En esta ocasión los rusos no son quienes
están sufriendo la invasión de potencias
extranjeras, sino que ellos mismos son los
invasores.
Lo que tiene muchas implicaciones que pueden
jugar en su contra.
Y, ojo, que en el Kremlin lo saben.
De ahí que con el ocaso del verano y la llegada
del otoño hayan intentado incrementar la
presión atacando objetivos civiles.
Pero, para contaros exactamente porque el
invierno ucraniano puede terminar convirtiéndose
en toda una pesadilla para Putiwn, el Kremlin
y las tropas rusas, vamos a destacar 4 motivos
principales.
Y sí, el primero de ellos tiene mucho que
ver justo con el propio teatro de operaciones,
o más bien, con luchar fuera de Rusia.
Hablamos, por supuesto, de los suministros
a las tropas.
Y es que, aunque la guerra está concentrada
en las zonas fronterizas - que son, en teoría,
las que Rusia puede abastecer mejor - lo cierto
es que en invierno esta misión puede no resultar
nada sencilla.
Y es que, veréis, buena parte del frente,
especialmente el de la región de Kherson,
está lejos de sus centros de suministros
y producción.
Porque lo cierto es que 8 años después de
su anexión, Crimea sigue siendo abastecida
fundamentalmente desde Rusia.
Y a ver, otras zonas de conflicto como el
óblast de Donetsk sí que cuentan con buenas
conexiones con Rostov del Don, una gran ciudad
industrial rusa de más de un millón de habitantes,
pero el resto del frente no tiene tanta suerte.
(Obviamente tener que movilizar equipos pesados
y grandes envíos de todo tipo de suministros
por suelos y carreteras congeladas no suele
ser una tarea nada sencilla.
Así que en invierno Rusia dependerá aún
mucho más del transporte por ferrocarril.
El problema es que las líneas férreas además
de ser mucho más rígidas - no llegan a todas
partes - también están más expuestas que
las carreteras.
Y si los ucranianos consiguen cortarlas con
ataques y sabotajes, entonces los rusos pueden
ver multiplicarse los problemas que ya tienen
para abastecer a su ejército.
Y en invierno la falta de suministros puede
ser decisiva.
Por contra, los ucranianos juegan en casa,
y eso en términos logísticos es una ventaja
enorme.)
Pero eso no es todo.
Para luchar en invierno hacen falta dos cosas:
preparación y equipamiento.
Pocas cosas se antojan más complicadas que
luchar a varios grados bajo cero y tener que
hacer frente a la nieve, el hielo, la congelación…
Pues bien, aquí los ucranianos pueden llevar
la delantera.
Sobre este punto…
En fin, creo que la mayoría ya conocéis
la historia:
(Las tropas movilizadas rusas están poco
entrenadas y carecen de equipos adecuados
para la guerra - JPost)
(Los soldados movilizados rusos hablan: “Hemos
sido tirados al frente sin apoyo” - Le Monde)
La enorme cantidad de bajas sufridas ha hecho
que los rusos tengan que tirar de reclutas
forzosos.
Es decir, nuevos soldados recientemente movilizados
a toda velocidad que en muchos casos prácticamente
no han recibido entrenamiento antes de ser
enviados al frente.
E, incluso, los que han tenido más fortuna
apenas han recibido una preparación del todo
insuficiente..
Y sí, podríamos pensar que los ucranianos
se enfrentan a una situación muy similar.
Sin embargo, hay algunas importantes diferencias:
primero, no es lo mismo jugar en casa y combatir
en tus propias ciudades que hacerlo en un
país extranjero sin conocer el terreno, sin
tener el apoyo de la población y con la moral
por los suelos.
Segundo, hoy Ucrania tiene en el campo de
batalla más soldados con experiencia profesional
que Rusia.
Aquí las Fuerzas de Defensa Territorial han
sido todo un éxito.
Y tercero muchos soldados ucranianos, soldados
profesionales o con cierta experiencia de
combate, están recibiendo entrenamiento de
primer nivel.
Por ejemplo, los británicos llevan meses
entrenando a tropas ucranianos, y ahora muchos
otros países europeos han empezado a hacer
lo propio.
(17 octubre 2022: Los Estados de la UE acuerdan
entrenar a soldados ucranianos como parte
de una nueva misión - Euronews)
Con lo cual a priori parece que si hablamos
de know how, de saber hacer, los ucranianos
también tienen ventaja sobre los rusos.
Y eso es algo que en invierno vale doble.
Pero sigamos.
El tercer gran motivo tiene que ver con el
equipamiento que tienen a su alcance los propios
soldados.
Desde prácticamente el principio de la invasión
rusa a Ucrania una de las cosas que más ha
llamado la atención es que muchos soldados
rusos no cuentan con equipos individuales
avanzados.
Y la cosa con el paso de los meses no ha hecho
más que empeorar.
(El ejército ruso no ha dado a los nuevos
soldados reclutados “absolutamente ningún
equipamiento”, forzando a las familias a
comprar blindaje y ropa para que los reclutados
tengan una “oportunidad de regresar” - Business
Insider)
Sabemos que 9 meses después de comenzar la
invasión los almacenes del ejército ruso
están tiritando.
Hay escasez de misiles, de tanques modernos,
de munición y, sí, también de equipos individuales.
(Combatir en condiciones de frío extremo,
hielo y nieve requiere de equipos específicos.
Por ejemplo, las botas de los soldados tienen
que ser especiales para soportar bajas temperaturas
y poder caminar sobre el hielo; y los ropajes
han de ser térmicos y a la vez ligeros para
permitir el movimiento.
Dada las condiciones climáticas de Rusia
podríamos pensar que su ejército está bien
abastecido de todas estas cosas, pero lo cierto
es que todo apunta a que no es así.
Las crónicas que nos están llegando desde
el frente apuntan a que los nuevos soldados
rusos llegan prácticamente con las manos
vacías.
Y desde luego los equipos modernos brillan
por su ausencia.)
Mientras tanto, los ucranianos llevan ya meses
recibiendo toneladas de equipamiento individual
adaptado al invierno procedente de sus aliados
occidentales.
Con lo cual es muy probable que el ejército
de Kyiv ya esté cubierto.
(La OTAN está enviando equipos a Ucrania
mientras las tropas se preparan para el invierno
Los países occidentales están acelerando
los envíos de ropa de invierno, nuevas rondas
de artillería y defensas contra drones a
Kyiv mientras las fuerzas ucranianas y rusas
se preparan para una lucha de meses en medio
del barro y el hielo.
- Politico)
Y exactamente lo mismo ocurre con el hardware
militar pesado
En Ucrania cuando empiezan las primeras nevadas
estas se acumulan y se convierten en duro
hielo que permanece prácticamente hasta la
llegada de la primavera.
Y después del hielo llega el barro, lo cual
puede terminar siendo incluso peor.
Todo esto hace que ambos ejércitos sean mucho
más propensos a usar las carreteras, que
suelen conservarse limpias, en lugar de intentar
avanzar campo a través o por caminos rurales.
Básicamente porque moverse por ahí puede
resultar siendo todo un infierno.
De hecho, no sé si recordaréis que en febrero
y marzo, durante el primer mes de la invasión
cuando todavía había nieve y hielo en Ucrania,
los rusos siempre avanzaban por las carreteras
principales, y ese fue uno de los motivos
por el que sus largos convoyes se volvieron
muy vulnerables.
¿Recordáis cuando camiones y blindados rusos
se quedaban atrapados porque sus neumáticos
explotaban al estar caducados?
¿Os acordáis de las emboscadas ucranianas
que terminaban con numerosos equipos rusos
calcinados?
Pues eso…
Y, claro, todo eso pasó en febrero y marzo
cuándo los rusos contaban con más menos
a su alcance y más diferencia respecto al
Ucraniano.
Pero imaginaos ahora.
Así que este invierno puede repetirse, salvando
las distancias, algo parecido…
Fijaos.
(Los rusos saben de sobra que sus anticuados
tanques, blindados y camiones no se desenvuelven
bien campo a través en invierno, con lo que
es probable que se vean menos enfrentamientos
en campo abierto.
Además, en el invierno las condiciones meteorológicas
son mucho más adversas, como las lluvias,
las nevadas, las tormentas o la niebla entorpecen
la operación de los drones, tan necesarios
para ambos bandos para fijar objetivos y utilizar
armas de precisión.
Por este motivo, una de las posibilidades
que se barajan de cara al invierno es que
la guerra, aún sin detenerse, entre en una
especie de fase de letargo en la que las operaciones
que veamos sean de mucha menor escala y desarrollos
mucho más lentos.
Sin embargo, al mismo tiempo, las duras condiciones
climáticas y los movimientos más difíciles
por el terreno hacen que los equipos sufran
mucho más.)
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Nada de esto juega tampoco a favor de los
rusos.
Una guerra más prolongada exige un esfuerzo
de suministros continuo y con el desgaste
de los equipos los rusos pueden tener muchos
más problemas.
Básicamente por el hecho de que Ucrania cuenta
con armamento pesado más moderno, e incluso
el que no lo es suele estar en mejores condiciones
de mantenimiento.
Por ejemplo, muchos de los tanques T-72 que
usa Ucrania hoy en día han sido donados por
Polonia, y han sido entregados en perfectas
condiciones de uso después de ser reacondicionados.
Y lo mismo ocurre con otros tanques y armas
de países como República Checa, por ejemplo.
Y no solo eso, los aliados de Ucrania en la
región como Polonia, Eslovaquia o la propia
República Checa reparan puntualmente equipos
militares ucranianos, e incluso los actualizan.
Hablamos de una cadena de mantenimiento, actualización
y modernización de armas que se ha creado
sobre la marcha y que está permitiendo a
los ucranianos estar unos cuantos pasos por
delante de Rusia.
Evidentemente no podemos saber que va a ocurrir
exactamente, pero todo apunta a que esta vez
el invierno no favorece a los intereses del
Kremlin.
Y quizás precisamente por eso es por lo que
hemos visto - y todavía seguimos viendo - como
la nueva apuesta de Rusia en esta guerra pasa
por llevar a los ucranianos de una vez por
todas a la mesa de negociación.
En esta línea la amenaza de usar armas nucleares
- hablaremos de ello muy pronto aquí en VisualPolitik
- y los ataques a las infraestructuras civiles
que veíamos al comienzo del vídeo cobran
mucho sentido.
Pero ahora llegados a este punto es turno
para ti: ¿crees que Rusia conseguirá soportar
un invierno en guerra mejor de lo esperado?
¿Piensas que los ucranianos deberían resistir
social y militarmente al embate ruso y al
chantaje energético o deberían abrirse a
negociar con Putin?
Déjanos tus opiniones aquí abajo, en los
comentarios.
¡Y recuerda¡ Si te ha gustado este vídeo
no te olvides de darle like y suscribirte
a nuestro canal para no perderte ninguna novedad.
También puedes ayudarnos a crear más y mejor
contenido sumándote a nuestra comunidad en
Patreon.
Te dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.